PROFESSOR: Visualizing Cultures
is a web-based history program
which John Dower and I
started in year 2001.
John Dower is an eminent
historian of modern Japan.
He won the Pulitzer
Prize in 1999
for his book Embracing Defeat.
I approached John in 2000 when
I knew that OpenCourseWare
was about to go up.
And I told John that
I thought that this
would be a great platform to
do something new with history,
specifically to look at history,
not just from text, which
is what historians do, but from
looking at images, visuals that
have been produced by people
from the historical era,
and to try to understand
what was going on.
John suprisingly said
yes, and so we started.
We didn't quite know what
we were doing at first,
but we got very lucky
with our first unit, which
is Commodore Matthew
Perry's arrival in Japan
in 1853, to open up Japan, which
had been essentially isolated,
closed, for 250 years.
And so you have America and
Japan come clashing together
in this one moment in history.
And from that, this explosion
of images from both sides--
Americans depicting
the Japanese,
and Japanese depicting Perry
and his men and his ships.
It's just wonderful.
And what's really interesting
is that when you look at images,
you get to see things that
you cannot get from written
material.
We found lots of images where
the Japanese were really
curious about Perry's men and
drawing costumes, instruments,
weapons in minute
detail, and with notes
to go along with them, showing
just sort of sheer curiosity.
Who are these people?
How do they live?
How do they talk?
And you saw the same
thing on Perry's side.
Perry brought his
own artist, Heine,
who was a 26-year-old artist
trained in Germany in sort
of the romantic style.
He just fell in love with Japan.
You can tell that in the images.
He absolutely fell in love
with this beautiful country,
so much so that
he would sometimes
paint himself into the picture,
interacting with the Japanese.
And so what you got
was this one artist
depicting Japan in a
very beautiful, very
affectionate way.
And that's what Americans saw
of Japan for the first time.
This is why even to this
day, in this country,
you have this image of Japan
as very beautiful, very
beautiful nature.
It really originates
with Heine's paintings.
And so we very much
follow the OCW principle
of not only making it
available and open and free,
but that everything is
licensed under Creative Commons
so that these images, which we
got from about 200 museums--
and these are major museums.
Boston MFA, Sackler
in Washington,
Hong Kong, British Museum--
we asked all of them
to sign an agreement
that we could present
their images on Visualizing
Japan on OpenCourseWare
under Creative Commons.
And so anyone coming in and
studying Visualizing Cultures
can take images and copy them,
distribute them, alter them
into their own material and
use them however, they wish.
One of the populations that
we really wanted to work with
were schoolteachers.
And so we did many, many
workshops over the years,
and we trained face-to-face
around 2,000 teachers.
I say we.
We worked with a wonderful group
out of University of Colorado
that specializes in creating
East Asian curriculum
and working with
teachers directly
to help them to incorporate
them into their classroom.
And so they ran these series of
workshops all over the country.
And as far as I know,
it's still being used.
So high school teachers,
university professors
tell us that they're using
it on a regular basis.
A couple of years
ago, a university
had an opening for assistant
professor in Japanese history,
and they had four finalists.
And they asked them how do
you teach Japanese history.
And three of them
apparently said
they used Visualizing Cultures.